foreign
[Music]
welcome to film Theory the show that
thinks it would be super sweet of you if
you would subscribe for more videos oh
gosh so are we I mean sorry it's just
really infectious all right the ooh has
rubbed off on me again after watching
too many YouTube shorts and seeing this
adorable yellow dog popping up all over
my feed in case you have no idea what
I'm talking about today we're diving
into the world of chicken nugget spelled
like um that spell check hates me in
this script if you've somehow missed
this incredibly viral series across
YouTube or Tick Tock or Instagram or
literally any website chicken nugget is
an animated micro series created by Kyra
kupetsky of BuzzFeed animation
chronicling The Wacky Adventures of an
adorable doggo named fittingly enough
chicken nugget as well as all his
friends who are named after items that
you might pick up at your local 7-Eleven
there's chicken's bestest friend in the
world cheeseburger the cat French fly
the dragon a being of pure good I scream
the bunny who may or may not actually be
a demon slushy the arctic fox who's
really into cosplay conventions and
fanfic Kofi the sheep and wolves
clothing sodipop the rambunctious red
panda who just wants to spread chaos as
well as various other side characters
that get into hijinks with chicken
nugget in the gang to borrow a phrase
this series is kind of like a box of
chocolates once you scroll into one
you're never quite sure what you're
gonna get from the hashtag relatable try
again try again
again to the LOL so Random
I love you
to the wow that was actually horrific
[Music]
es I love glitter too once it enters the
space it never leaves its particles
permanent and unending and while these
characters might seem innocent and
cuddly on the outside
bubbles
[Music]
[Applause]
if you keep watching these micro videos
You'll soon discover something deeper
going on just under the surface
let me tell you loyal theorists you guys
delivered with this one taken to Twitter
GT Live's comment sections even the
theorist subreddit to recommend that we
look into chicken nugget but I gotta be
honest when I first saw chicken nugget
recommendations popping up all across my
feeds I thought it had something to do
with kindergarten that theorist classic
game with a different kind of chicken
nugget hello Internet welcome to nugget
Siri where only the most deserving of
nuggets wisdom are permitted to watch
but after taking a dive into the series
wow I cannot believe that I let this one
almost Pass Me By and with the news that
BuzzFeed animations teamed up with
frederator to make a new animated series
adapted from the shorts now seems like
the perfect time to dig into this one
and boy let me tell you there is a lot
hidden beneath the cute and cuddly art
of this one what on the surface seems
like an innocent and wholesome series of
fun jokey videos about furry friendos
named after food is actually a series
asking some pretty heavy existential
questions about what it means to be
yourself to believe in yourself all
packed inside of a wholesome
[Music]
okay mostly wholesome and digestible
crust like a delicious chicken nugget so
grab your ketchup and honey mustard
loyal theorists we're digging in now
when you decide to decode the lore of a
series like chicken nuggets sometimes it
can be difficult to figure out where to
start unfortunately most series like
this don't really compile all their most
important lore bits into a compilation
video called something like chicken
nugget lore part oh that's uh that's
exactly what they did with this one
nothing says hey go call matpat to cover
your series like adding the word lore
and making it a multi-part series so
let's just explain what's going on here
so we get a view of the big picture all
of this lore content begins with an
introduction of a new character into the
lovable cast the personified clock and
Tumblr sexy man known as vessel
embodiment of time nice to make your
acquaintance middle animal friends what
the heck sex now right off the bat bezel
doesn't fit in for a lot of reasons he's
not an animal
he looks so deeply out of place looking
like that hmm
you're right
nor is he chibi oh oh fine you want me
to blend in more conform fine
happy well at least he's trying also
worth noting that he's the only
character not named after an item that
you'd find in a typical fast food drive
through a bezel is the ring that
surrounds a watch and holds the
protective glass covering the face in
place so appropriate for the character
but not exactly something you'd want to
eat bezel is first introduced as a thorn
in everyone's side reminding them of the
fleeting nature of time itself Read It
and Weep kid days nearly over how have
you spending he's also responsible for
shipping the characters together but I
mean like we've all done it what are you
doing I don't mind me I'm simply putting
the things I like in this corner
[Music]
this eventually brings bezel into
conflict with both French fly and ice
cream who are both unlike the rest of
the cast you see both French fly and ice
cream are interdimensional beings french
fry is actually a representative of pure
good and ice cream is the Demonic
personification of Pure Evil both are
trying to influence the world of their
side but this conflict of good versus
evil quickly takes a back seat for
another type of Trope you're a harbinger
of darkness and a blight on this world I
should send you to the deepest pits of
the Netherworld
stopping you
yeah opposites certainly seem to be
attracting in this case now that right
there is an interesting setup for a
conflict with a ton of hidden lore right
a battle of good with French Fry versus
evil with ice cream versus chaos with
bezel over the fate of the world all
with these cute adorable talking animals
trapped in the middle but it's not the
world that these three are fighting over
it's just control over one of the
characters chicken nugget what are you
even here for anyhow I think you and I
both know you're not the only one who's
keeping an eye on the strange
occurrences surrounding that puppy
strange occurrences you say like what
well aside from summoning demons or
dragons or whatever we see that chicken
nugget has some sort of control over his
body that the other normal animals don't
and they're all aware of it let me be
clear
that's better y'all ever wish you could
just be long
you do belong
you misunderstand
[Music]
you can even change things about other
people let's trade what
meows now all of this could just be
funny jokes or an art style thing in
shows with similar art Direction like
Adventure Time or Steven Universe the
characters often have exaggerated
features they can stretch and bend their
bodies and limbs in ways that feel
inhuman their faces can transform into
something funny or scary at the drop of
a hat most of the time this is just
meant to be a fun art decision there's
no deeper meaning other than it's just a
cartoon bro but I don't believe that to
be the case with chicken nugget I think
all of these things are literally
happening in universe and that they
aren't necessarily supposed to be
happening why well it's simple chicken
nugget this dumb little pupper with a
permanent thousand yard stare is
actually literally a God he still
doesn't know
he's a god makes sense right I mean dog
is just God backwards anyway that is why
all these strange things keep happening
around him chicken nuggets body moving
in strange ways the weird creepy gnomes
everywhere why a dragon demon and the
embodiment of time keep following him
around trying to sway him to their side
and if you can't see the advantages to
all this bezel straight up spells it out
for us with a VHS styled explainer video
classic theorist Trope love to see it
etched into the fabric of the universe
demigod
Earth
neon recognition to his own selfish
desire and just to dot our eyes and
cross our T's here we definitely know
that this demigod must be referring to
chicken nugget why but when bezel says
that the demigod's destiny is to warp
reality beyond recognition to his own
selfish desire we see the world
transform into a land of frogs and
cheeseburgers who have chicken nuggets
favorite things I mean his best friend
is literally a cat named cheeseburger
wearing a cheeseburger hat as for frogs
why do you like them so much what's not
to like about froggies
I mean just look at them just a little
gentleman with more chickens power seems
to be growing he no longer seems to be
affected when the other powerful
characters use their powers on him dumb
online arguments wish I could give a
hoot your wish is my command
well it didn't work I'm getting stronger
I just don't got no time for nonsense no
more he can read people's thoughts you
do count if you're LGBT you're LGBT oh
thanks how did you read my thoughts he
even seems to be starting to break the
fourth wall sometimes it feels like I'm
just
puppet on a stage available for whatever
Shenanigans happen next
what's happening if you pause at just
the right moment of the short you'll see
a picture of the real life animators
working on the short in the real world
as chicken stares directly at the camera
that's not even mentioning the smaller
creepier stuff like this
it's a surprisingly intense setup for a
series about cuddly cartoon animals and
it leaves us with a lot of interesting
places where it could lead with a clear
battle between three sides and a doggo
goto that may dictate the entire fate of
the Universe on one side we have bezel
instigating chaos slowly trying to
reveal chicken nuggets Destiny to him by
planting subtle ideas into his head
for time is an infinite dance
he's also trying to reveal the nature of
this reality to chicken nugget helping
him break through that fourth wall cool
boy you got here yeah I guess it is kind
of neat I guess I kind of never really
noticed it on the other side of the
battle we have French fly and ice cream
who would love to recruit chicken nugget
but have accepted that they probably
won't be able to so instead they're
trying to Shield chicken nugget from the
truth but they're kind of at a total
loss for what to do you know why bezel's
here right yeah I just thought we did
everything right we did do everything
right he's wrong that said they do have
themselves a nice little backup plan for
when things go south so
right and he does destroy the world what
do you want to do next he's not going to
it's gonna be fine it will I can find a
nice pocket dimension for us it'll be so
nice
uh and lastly in the middle we have
chicken nugget who doesn't seem to be
handling all this very well it's
affecting his waking hours Let's sing
the clock guy said about empty voids is
kind of starting to freak me out
wait
do I even have a house
sometimes it feels like I'm just
pop it on a stage available for whatever
Shenanigans happen next and the sleeping
ones
and for now that's where a lot of the
lore of chicken nuggets stands but I
believe that we can actually take it a
step further I think that we can make a
pretty good guess about where this story
is going and the themes that it's going
to unpack first of all it seems pretty
darn clear that chicken nugget is going
to learn the true nature of his powers
and soon and that is gonna cause a lot
of Chaos in the last clip from the lore
video we see the character sodipop drawn
a happy picture of the whole cast having
fun but as it's hung up on the fridge
the music gets ominous as the picture
starts to fall clearly foreshadowing
that the fun Carefree shorts from early
on in the series are going to be
evolving into something more Sinister in
the description of the lore video it
even says quote here's the start of a
chaotic Arc in chicken nugget chaos just
like what bezel's trying to sow into
this world to awaken chicken nuggets
full power but then what's gonna happen
as a part of that story well honestly
it's a bit difficult to predict this is
the sort of Series where bezel could
reveal chicken nuggets Destiny only for
the doggo to say cool and then move on
never mentioning it all again but that
honestly wouldn't be very fun nor do I
think it's the big plan that they have
built for this thing instead I think
chicken nugget is going to have to
Grapple with the truth about himself and
really struggle with it as a part of his
identity that right there has been one
of the biggest themes of chicken nuggets
so far the theme of acceptance of
reality of accepting who you truly are
and it manifests itself in multiple ways
across the series for example one way is
accepting the idea of mortality that no
matter what you want or what you do time
is always going to continue to March
forward as I showed earlier bezel is
quick to remind everyone of that fact
how do you
your clock's ticking every day and it's
something that these characters have
already started tackling for example in
one short cheeseburger asks French fly
and ice cream if they plan on getting
married but french fry says that they'll
need at least another 10 000 years
before they're ready for it and as ice
cream points out you'll be dead before
it happens in another after sodipop asks
slushy what kind of stuff she wore when
she was younger slushy has driven into a
quarter life crisis and in an attempt to
recapture that lost time she re-enters
her goth phase I have to go back
thank you
oh yes acceptance of Aging though is
only one facet of this another one is
accepting your own identity and that
right there is a huge part of the series
this is perfectly embodied by the
character Kofi she is literally a sheep
in Wolf's clothing she feels more at
home in a different body and is doing
her best to make that her reality for
explicitly she has several moments where
she learns to accept herself and that
she doesn't need to conform to others
expectations people don't really get me
sometimes maybe I am too weird guess I'm
just different that's okay though
characters like slushy encourage others
to embrace their interests no matter how
cringe they might be what you doing
writing a fanfic about my self-insert
dating a character I really like isn't
that kind of cringe no and you know why
because it makes me happy crunch culture
is dead write those fanfics cosplay
those characters even chicken nugget
gives cheeseburger some body positive
affirmation hey chicken
chubby yeah
very chubby and nice and good and
beautiful click for the hug and this
theme right here acceptance of who you
are no matter who you are it's gonna be
playing a huge role in this lore as the
series goes on I don't know about you
but if I were in chicken nuggets pause
and was on the cusp of discovering that
I was a demigod with the potential to
alter the world to my own will and
destroy the universe it would kind of
freak me out a little bit just just a
smidge and any potential feelings of
shame or low self-worth coming from that
well it's gonna outwardly affect
everyone around him we already see in
the series how chicken nugget holds
himself back despite having immense
power you got such a cute little baby
voice maybe when I grill up I'll lose it
wait you're grown why do you still have
one
equipping medical condition if chicken
nugget wanted an adult sounding voice he
could have one but his internalized
feelings are the things holding him back
and that's just the tip of the iceberg
for the things that chicken's gonna have
to deal with thankfully though he's
surrounded by the best people to help in
this sort of situation A supportive best
friend like cheeseburger a motherly
figure encouraging him to embrace
himself like slushy someone actively on
the same journey of self-acceptance like
Kofi a literal angel and devil on his
shoulder to keep him balanced and french
fry and ice cream and a little chaos
Gremlin and sodipop just for the fun of
it they're the ones that are ultimately
gonna help keep chicken nugget grounded
helping him through whatever god-like
self-realization he's going to be forced
through and they're not gonna do it
through some Epic Quest or Adventure but
they're gonna do it through the mundane
the everyday things that they're already
doing drawing going to lunch relaxing in
a field whatever sometimes life isn't
about the amazing and exciting future
but the here and now and the friends
that you choose to keep maybe the world
that chicken nugget occupies is just a
figment of his imagination or the whims
of an animator but the important thing
is that he spends his time with the
friends that he's made along the way hey
but hey that's just a theory a film
Theory and cuts
[Music]
foreign